vamos a seguir con algo de risa y con
esto que tal vez nos pueden hacer
cuestionar un poco no hay decir como
esto de que la risa puede relacionarse
con con la economía y pues para esto
hemos invitado también a una persona que
está relacionada con este mundo y pues
sé que para él sobre todo cree que el
mundo puede cambiar si todos reímos y de
ahí el título de la ponencia que
tendremos en esta mañana castigan riendo
amores que sin ser una traducción
literal al español pues vamos a decir
que qué mejor que el poder de la risa
junto a nosotros pues de nuestro
invitado y próximo expositor es de
escritor de comedia para stand up para
comedias de canales web y otras
plataformas sin importar cuál es el tema
que podamos tratar en estas
circunstancias pueden ser complejos
difíciles y por supuesto relacionando
esto con el humor
la carta de presentación de ave
jaramillo pues es bastante extensa él es
pionero del stand up en quitó además de
destacarse con su colaboración en
proyectos web como enchufe tv piloto
automático la avena cósmica y la foca
ave jaramillo se grado en la élite en
literatura en la pontificia universidad
católica del ecuador y tiene un posgrado
en humor para programas de
entretenimiento otorgado por la pompeu
fabra de barcelona en españa así que a
ven bienvenido y cuéntanos un poco cómo
podemos relacionar la risa con la
economía
[Aplausos]
primero muy buenos días a mí me gusta
muchísimo dirigirme a audiencias que
están digiriendo siempre ayuda un poco
no que estén
que esté en madrid para relajarse tal
vez contenga un poco menos científico
pero ocasional si tiene algo de ciencia
y es lo que intento demostrar está esta
mañana acá sí gracias a la presentación
yo me dedico al stand up y la vida me ha
llevado por el camino de la comedia he
hecho de la comedia mi profesión y ya
son 12 años que estoy haciendo stand up
y gracias que son 12 años que estoy
haciendo estándar y después de 12 años
todavía recuerdo las palabras de mi
viejo de mi padre y cuando le dije que
quería dedicarme a eso y recuerdo
todavía el momento que me quedó viendo a
los ojos y me dijo mi hijo tú no eres
chistoso
pero tenía razón
porque en casi el 100% de los casos la
comedia no es una esencia es decir uno
no es o no es estos uno puede hacerse
chistoso porque la comedia implica un
montón de cosas y entre ellas está la
observación yo estudié literatura ese
fue mi primer camino
originalmente mi plan de vida era eso
era una academia de la literatura
escribir analizar e investigar el tiempo
y la falta de trabajo y de buena comedia
y cuando entré este mundo también entre
la comedia desde el punto de vista
literario y una de las cosas que más me
marcó en mi carrera fue
entender la commedia dell'arte estudiar
la comedia del arte italiana y encontré
una máxima en la comida del arte que que
me llamó muchísimo la atención y que
creo que fue mi primer paso a entender
que hay una fuerza en la comedia es el
nombre de la ponencia es castigado
riendo amores no abro las dignos es si
lo está pronunciando bien pero cuando
leí la traducción me llegó como un poco
como una explosión que es riéndose
cambian las costumbres
el poder de la risa altera y yo le he
echo la culpa a dos características
super importantes de la comedia la
primera es la educación la comedia te
enseña sin enseñar
parece que no te está diciendo algo pero
sin embargo te dice y la segunda y es la
que más me gusta la comedia humanista
el ser humano es el único animal que
puede reírse que puede realmente ver
algo entender la comicidad de algo y
reaccionar con la risa y eso nos hace
muy muy muy humanos
cuando entendí estas dos cosas comencé a
trabajar y como les dije es un trabajo
de observar de mejorar de caerse de
jalarse desde ese show donde nadie se
ríe de tener esos donde todo el mundo se
ríe entender qué mecanismos están
funcionando qué mecanismos no están
funcionando entonces ahí es cuando
insisto me di cuenta que toda esa
observación la comedia está ahí en un
montón de cosas entonces para unir esta
ponencia con la economía que me resultó
súper difícil cuando me llamaron del
banco centrales dije pero como que te
quedes de qué voy a hablar yo
me di cuenta que la observación es el
primer paso para la educación para
enseñar y ustedes que asumo que la
mayoría son economistas phd científicos
gente que trabaja en un mundo muy
[Música]
de cata que se ríen porque no sé por qué
sí no
me trajeron
[Música]
y yo digo es gente que puede enseñar que
puede que es que tiene que comunicar
conceptos muy complicados todavía
recuerdo cuál es el proceso que yo tengo
el momento de escribir un chiste porque
a veces la gente me dice si va ahí pero
es que tú eres exitoso the legend
exitosísimo el colegio no yo aprendí yo
les cuento esta historia
yo trato de ser un show al año en el
medio de lo posible y siempre tengo un
proceso de un año el año anterior
escribir chistes para ese show entonces
tengo que ver de dónde sacó los donde
saco los chistes para un parón show de
stand up o para un proyecto audiovisual
el año pasado uno de los que mejor me
funcionó es uno que tiene que ver con lo
que tiene que ver con la torre inclinada
de pisa porque yo cuando conocí a la
torre inclinada de pisa lo que más me
sorprendió fue que que sea famosa porque
básicamente la torre inclinada de pisa
es una torre que es famosa porque está
mal hecha sé escribir han hecho bien la
torre nadie que nadie le para bolas
nadie estaría ahí pendiente de la torre
inclinada de pisa pero como hicieron la
torre hicieron mal calcularon mal la
torre sur y no se quedaron locos porque
no se cayó
y yo digo es como si hubieran hecho el
famosísimo
entonces yo cuando vi la turbina davis
de pizza en directo me sorprendió la
cantidad de turistas gringos y coreanos
que estaban tomando fotos japonesas
latinos y yo me indigné como ecuatoriano
porque les dije hoy en ustedes ustedes
les gusta y les gusta esta torre porque
está porque está mal hecha vengan a
ecuador
[Música]
aquí todo está mal hecho
claro yo recuerdo que cuando hablaba de
eso en el puente los cuencanos en cuenta
que yo cuando conseguí puentes rotos
dije cerró este puesto se rompió nunca
repararon
y se convirtió un referente de la ciudad
de eso pero entonces claro cuando yo
decía eso alguien me dijo no pero cómo
puedo hacer quedar mal al país hay gente
que se tome serio de comedia esa gente
no lo entiendo por y gente que dice no
gracias quedar mal al país qué te pasa
que te crees bla bla bla bla bla bla
entonces yo cuando me sacaste ese chiste
yo analizaba eso claro me di cuenta de
que en mi cabeza tenía así mucho tiempo
yo cuando empecé a trabajar en estándar
no me daba el dinero para solo trabajar
estándar yo trabajaba de corrector de
estilo en un periódico tenía que hacer
un viaje muy largo yo vivía en la
kennedy y mi viaje siempre pasaba al
lado de un autor a un poste de luz que
estaba inclinado que estaba dañado y se
mandó cartas del municipio con la gente
del barrio hablábamos de lo peligroso
que era nunca repararon entonces yo
siempre tenía esa imagen de así como la
torre inclinada de pisa y el poste
creado de la calle
y eso me ayudó mucho hacer como este
jueguito de que bueno por ahí puede ser
el chiste como yo trabajaré de la
observación era darme cuenta del mundo y
darle un giro a esta cuestión de cómo
entender el mundo entonces ahí entró
mi pasado como estudiantes de literatura
una vez leí un ensayo de borges lo voy a
parafrasear este momento borges algún
momento para definir a la poesía él
decía que la poesía no te enseña nada
nuevo nunca te enseña nada nuevo la
poesía lo que hace la poesía un gran
poema que te conmueve el que te choca es
el poema que te hace recordar lo que
tenía adentro guardado que salió que
hace que salga que fluya es cuando yo le
di a eso guardando las debidas
distancias y dije esto es exactamente lo
que pasa la comedia y un chiste un
chiste funciona cuando la gente que lo
escucha de alguna manera se siente
identificado y es la clásica la clase
que uno puede ver cuando está parado acá
la reacción el público cuando un chiste
funciona muy bien al menos siempre hay
una persona que está con su compañero
con su pareja con su pana con su primo y
es lo que igualito
así eres vos
entonces y claro es que la gente le
encanta sentirse identificada porque la
comedia te hace ver cosas del mundo que
no habías visto la comedia te enseña sin
enseñar entonces yo comencé a trabajar
comenzar a trabajar varios años en esto
de hacer estándar escribir chistes de
ver y eso me llevó a preguntar me
acuerdo del origen de esto porque porque
nos enseña así porque básicamente la
comedia nos suaviza el mundo el mundo un
lugar muy duro es un lugar muy difícil
muy cruel muy poco justo ustedes son
economistas deben saber eso
aún así este mundo tiene un montón de
hermosura que está escondida que la
comedia lo que hace es [ __ ] el absurdo
el ridículo el fracaso y darle la vuelta
y permitirte ver eso por eso es súper
interesante la comedia
nació en grecia como respuesta a la
tragedia que como género el teatro
cómico nace como una respuesta a la
tragedia en grecia la tragedia tiene
personajes que viven en mundos horribles
donde se acuesta un personaje se acuesta
con su mamá sin saberlo mata a su papá y
cuando se entera se saca los ojos claro
entonces cuando el público griego veía
eso veía un mundo donde los dioses
decidían el control del mundo y los no
podían hacer nada entonces en cien a
gobiernos por eso la tragedia te cae
cuando tienes esto tu respuesta
evolutiva es devolver y darle la vuelta
a eso y ahí nace la comedia es poder
reírte del mundo ponerse por encima y
verlo desde arriba es decir yo puedo más
que esto y te puedes reír pues por eso
la comedia juega muchísimo con esta
cuestión de la máscara la máscara amor a
la máscara grotesca porque te oculta la
verdad pero al mismo tiempo de la
muestra porque te permite reír y al
mismo tiempo te permite aprender
entonces tú ves un es aprendizaje y
humanidad tiene
uno de los mejores caminos para enseñar
en mi experiencia personal a mí me ha
tocado muchísimo trabajar con públicos
de todo tipo pero uno de los públicos
más duros con los que tengo que trabajar
ha sido el público de los académicos
porque la academia es otra vez la que a
la que más le duele reírse porque
siempre tiene el velo de la seriedad
entonces todo le puede ser un académico
que se ríe casi siempre pero para
enseñar la seriedad es un camino mucho
más duro que la comedia entonces
estoy acá entonces
en mí en mi camino trabajando en
estándar comencé a trabajar a trabajar
haciendo vídeos
cuando llegué no solamente me pedía que
vaya a hacer shows para para
para bares para teatros una vez le
pidieron hacer un show para una especie
de soltero fue súper incómodo
claro porque llega uno no sabe hasta que
el punto mediante stripper y payaso
pero también me llamaron para hacer
transmisión de conocimiento científico
conocimiento económico entonces tengo
proyectos web que ustedes pueden revisar
los que mencionaron como la foca novela
cómica que de nuevo cambien lo que estoy
encontrando la comedia que estoy
muchísimo por enseñar ya recuerde por
ejemplo a big man la primera vez que
vieron un taller para dar académicos
para enseñar en métodos de comedia para
que ellos puedan enseñar y yo cuando
estaba preparando eso y descubrí que lo
que estaba haciendo a repetir a lo que
yo vi cuando tenía 14 años tal vez acabe
o por el nivel de calvas creo que gente
de los 90 acá
cuando vieron televisión tal vez conmigo
y vieron el mundo the big man donde bolt
salud acompañado una rata se enseñaba
conceptos científicos sentidos
entonces yo recuerdo mucho mas bastards
the big man donde me reía donde es donde
me divertía con el mejor prendía que las
clases de ciencias naturales del colegio
jove yo recuerdo mucho más recuerdo
mucho más cómo funciona la fricción
porque se causan terremotos cuáles son
los colores del arcoíris por big man que
por el profesor de ciencias naturales
del colegio es cuando yo creo que
comienzo a trabajar en comedia me doy
cuenta que ese es el camino y por eso yo
comencé a comenzar a trabajar temas
súper complejos que parece que no se
pueden tratar con comedia como temas de
economía explicar por qué la crisis
petrolera efecto alcoholismo el año
pasado hace unos años perdón porque
explicarle el aborto desde el punto de
vista científico o explicar por ejemplo
la crisis que está viviendo el pesca
galápagos
el incesto es súper difícil pero hay
cualquier camino para explicar un montón
de temas por ejemplo en el incesto se
nos dificultó muchísimo empezar porque
no sabíamos cómo poner con medio un tema
tan duro y tan feo hasta que nos
acordamos de los mil pinela
claro es una pareja
que siempre canta canciones de amor pero
que son hermanos y se queda con ellos
obviamente que están realmente no
tuvieron ningún tipo de contacto sexual
bueno espero pero
pero también tú descubres que esto ayuda
muchísimo ayuda muchísimo como que la
gente identificarse suavizarse
humanizarse y entender se aprende
muchísimo entonces yo recomiendo mucho
usar la comedia para enseñar la comedia
puede casi puede castigar lo que es lo
que tenemos metido grabado nos puede
alterar y nos puede ayudar a cambiar el
mundo eso es muy muy muy importante y
para cerrar un poquito mi herencia
literaria yo creo que le debo muchísimo
muchísimo a este concepto cómo está este
entendimiento de la comedia a uno de los
personajes más entrañables de la
historia de la humanidad que es el
quijote es que no ha leído la novela
recomiendo que la lean
es por algo una de las principales
novelas de la historia de la humanidad
porque bigote es un personaje en esencia
cómico el quijote es principalmente un
personaje muy humano este tipo que se
vuelve loco por los libros de
caballerías y cambia su visión del mundo
es un reflejo muy grande de lo que somos
como seres humanos nuestra visión del
mundo puede cambiar a partir de nosotros
y enfrentarse a la ridiculez que eso nos
causa nos hace grandes y el momento que
hacemos eso podemos decirnos que como
seres humanos como hombres y mujeres
podemos aprender así que les invito a
que se rían les invito a que no se tomen
en serio
les invito a que la pasen bien muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]